the movie Renfield asked what Dracula's
relationship with his familiar Renfield
might look like in the 21st century well
there'd be a lot of therapy and even
more blood
Renfield is usually a propulsive and
Loud movie but for one moment before its
big finale there is calm Renfield and
police officer Rebecca Quincy recover in
a small cafe after a grisly battle and
an apartment complex you know when
something crazy happens and someone's
like it's okay I've seen way worse
everything I saw you do today is going
to be my way worse it's there that
Renfield comes clean about leaving his
wife and child behind to serve as
Dracula's familiar but the moment is
short-lived the duo quickly learns that
Count Dracula has a powerful new Ally
the Lobo crime family not only that but
these gangsters have taken Quincy's
sister hostage this development ensures
Quincy and Renfield both have high
stakes during the climax of the movie
Renfield is as ever impressed with
Quincy's willingness to charge into
battle against their enemies seeing
renfield's admiration Quincy reminds him
that anyone can stand up to bullies and
abusive people it's at this point that
Renfield decides to help her battle the
combined power of Dracula and the mob
they can't rush in the battle
empty-handed this is where renfield's
Decades of experience fighting Dracula's
enemies becomes invaluable he knows the
best weapons to use when you need to
kill a vampire
as the unforgettable opening chords and
My Chemical Romance is na na na kick in
one thing becomes very apparent it's
time for an energetic Montage Renfield
and Quincy start to gather all the tools
they need to fight Dracula and his
minions as they scramble across New
Orleans looking for crucifixes and
anything else associated with killing
vampires their determination to finally
take out this blood-sucking creep grows
ever higher but the most important part
of the Duo's Arsenal is bugs since
Renfield gets his Supernatural powers
from chomping on insects it's time to go
to Every bait and tackle store he could
find and buy as many tiny Critters as
possible to consume this Mission results
in a gross out comedy moment where
Renfield gobbles down a horde of insects
loudly in the passenger seat of Quincy's
vehicle completely grossing around in
the process it's not a pretty sight but
it's a necessary one once Renfield is
powered up he's ready to confront danger
head on
as the finale begins Renfield easily
takes down random goons with his powers
but it's when he finally encounters
Teddy Lobo that the real battle begins
Dracula has chosen him as his new
familiar and as a result he has been
given Supernatural Powers just like
Renfield this discovery changes the
nature of the battle Renfield has to use
everything he's got to fight the new and
improved version of himself during their
Skirmish Lobo constantly taunts his
rival including emphasizing how he's the
yen to renfield's Yang as Lobo viciously
attacks Renfield shouts we barely met
twice it calls out how little the two
know about each other and how ridiculous
lobo's claim is the battle between the
two familiars rages for a while before
Renfield finally gains the upper hand in
the final moment to the battle Dracula's
original servant takes out Lobo in the
most over-the-top way possible he kicks
the mobster so hard in the stomach that
he spews out fluids from both his mouth
and his rear before dying
well Renfield is all fighting Teddy Lobo
Quincy makes her way to the office of
elolobo where she hopes to find her
sister when she arrives Ella greets a
police officer then vanishes and the
windows to the office are sealed shut
with every window closed sunlight can't
enter the room and harm the dark figure
creeping up behind her Dracula deck down
a fabulous red-colored cloak Dracula
doesn't go for the jugular instead he
decides to make Rebecca an offer her
sister is dying from incredibly vicious
wounds and the medicine a mortal man
can't save her the Blood of Dracula
which can heal any wound is her sister's
only hope it's a particularly tense
moment as the sisters lost their father
to Lobo earlier in the movie Renfield
bursts into the room as Quincy moves
closer to Dracula's Embrace Renfield
begs her not to give in to the Dark Lord
but she says that she doesn't care about
the consequences of being Dracula's
servant she can't lose another member of
her family Quincy finally hugs Dracula
closely the whole moment is a stunt her
real goal is to get close enough to the
vampire to activate the shutters and
open the windows unfortunately for
Quincy her immediate betrayal of Dracula
doesn't go as planned as she mashes the
button to open the windows nothing
happens her desperation Rises as she
continues to match the controller things
look Grim for the cop until finally
after several more presses the windows
finally cooperate and open bathing
Dracula and sunlight as the light pours
in Dracula howls in pain and catches
fire he escapes by turning into a pack
of bats though now they're in the Flames
as he flees the Dracula bats crash into
Ella Lobo still in the hallway and knock
her out cold Renfield and Quincy chase
after the dark lord and track him to a
torture chamber in the Lobo family
compound the battle between the three of
them continues in the foreboding room
though badly burned by the sunlight
Dracula's far from defeated he's still
an incredibly intimidating figure at one
point he levitates into the air and
grabs Quincy by the neck with Renfield
collapsed on the ground succumbing to
his wounds this is the moment where all
hope was lost fortunately for Quincy her
arms are free enough to stab Dracula in
the foot it's a move that the vicious
vampire initially laughs off as being a
foolhardy attempt to save her life
however this maneuver wasn't meant to
kill Dracula or free yourself instead it
was meant to force some blood out of
Dracula's injured foot so it can drop
onto Renfield and heal Dracula's old
familiar the plan works like a charm
with the mystical blood Reviving
Renfield who promptly saves Quincy from
the clutches of Dracula it's time for
the final confrontation over the course
of the movie Renfield has grown as an
individual through his work in the
support meetings sorry to interrupt are
you okay I need to get out of a toxic
relationship
the most important lesson he learned at
the meetings is that victims in toxic
relationships are the ones with all of
the Power he violently hammers this
point home to Dracula while he's
pummeling his former boss Quincy
proceeds to trap the vampire into
spiritual containment field she learned
the spell through some kind of weird
Wiccan tumbler after the dust and blood
settle Renfield has finally taken his
power back from Dracula and stopped the
evil creature of the night dead in his
tracks
it's not enough to keep Dracula
suspended in a circle though magical or
otherwise Renfield and Quincy have to
completely destroy the Beast luckily the
final battle took them to a torture
chamber filled with weapons Renfield and
Quincy go to town dismembering burning
and torturing the vampire in every way
imaginable renfield's recurring
narration throughout the movie Pops in
again to remark to the audience that
neither he nor his partner is sure what
can actually kill Dracula so they try to
just throw everything at the wall and
see what sticks going this route
inspires some of the more amusingly
heightened gags in all of Renfield the
inexplicable presence of items like the
cement mixer and an ice cube tray as
ways of brutally killing Dracula or
amusing sight gags this is especially
true sensei's cartoonish vampire killing
weapons are far from common in the
pantheon of vampire movies eventually
The Barrage of sight gags and creative
murders gives way to Renfield and Quincy
dropping a bunch of chopped up cubes of
Dracula's corpse into a pit Renfield
notes in the narration that he's far
from certain that this will kill off
Dracula forever but he knows that at the
very least the Dark Lord won't heal
easily
with Dracula defeated it's time to take
care of one last villain Renfield and
Quincy returned to the scene of their
final confrontation with Alba Lobo still
incapacitated from Dracula's flights
Quincy manages to cup the mobster and
send her off to prison Quincy finally
rescues her sister who has been brought
back to life with Dracula's blood the
pair reconciled their differences share
a hug and then Quincy heads over to
regroup with Renfield now free of his
master the former familiar has
understandably complicated emotions
swirling around inside him though he
still doubts that he's much better than
Dracula Quincy reassures Renfield that
he is given something important to the
world when he asks what that is Quincy
says that he's shown that it's never too
late for someone to be a hero it's an
exchange that closes out renfield's
character Arc and lays The Core theme of
the entire film Bearer life begins to
calm down after Dracula's defeat as the
movie closes we discover that renfield's
narration has all occurred while
speaking to his support group for
victims of abusive relationships if you
were to stop focusing on his needs what
would happen
he won't grow to full power exactly he
won't grow to full power however any
twist perfectly suited to renfield's
world the members of the group are all
the resurrected victims of Dracula's
attack from earlier in the movie
Renfield has brought them all back from
the dead using the Dark Lord's blood
though it might be a little convenient
to bring back all of these characters so
easily it's a fitting end for a film
that relishes its silliness and
over-the-top antics the camera even
lingers on a jug of blood situated next
to cookies and napkins for the final
shot of the entire feature
viewers expecting Renfield to conclude
with teases for Further Adventures
involving Nicolas Cage's Dracula will
leave the film sorely disappointed
despite Renfield not being sure that he
and Quincy have truly destroyed Dracula
the movie ends on a definitively
standalone note there are no hints for
potential sequels or even an after the
credits scene it's clear that Renfield
is meant to function as a one-off story
fans can still hope though the chemistry
between Nicholas Cage and Nicholas Holtz
is the absolute standout of the film and
it would be a shame to not revisit their
Dynamic
marvelous attire
an Aquafina as always delivers a
hilarious Counterpoint to the violent
existence of her superpowered partner
seeing how Renfield matures with his new
knowledge of overcoming toxic
relationships could be a great starting
point for Sequel and it would be
hilarious to watch how he brings his
emotional maturity with him to battle
creatures of the night only time success
and maybe a little bit of Dracula's
blood will tell
[Music]